(Transcribed by TurboScribe. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Did you know that
in Pakistan, the monthly
salary of 41 crore
rupees is like this?
And the monthly salary
of 38 thousand rupees
is like this.
And approximately 40%
of Pakistanis live on
this salary or on
a salary less than
this.
I would like to
show you how they
spend their lives.
Those who have such
a high salary and
those with such a
high salary.
And among them.
So the reason for
which I want to
show you this difference
is the difference between
rich and poor.
So let's start with
the 38 thousand rupees
monthly salary.
Let's assume that I
am a landlord, I
live in Lahore.
I am absolutely single,
I have no children.
And I have got
this job of a
guard in Gulbarg, which
gives me 38 thousand
rupees per month.
This 38 thousand rupees
is a little more
than the lowest salary
of the government.
At this level, approximately
40% of Pakistanis
earn as much as
me or less than
me.
I have 38 thousand
rupees per month, none
of which pays taxes.
So how will I
spend it?
First of all, I
will look for a
house.
I will get this
room for 38 thousand
rupees.
And within this salary,
I can only buy
a house on rent,
not buy a house.
I will spend 12
thousand rupees on food,
which is 400 rupees
per day.
If I cook food
at home, I will
focus on very cheap
things.
Like rice, lentils,
etc.
To go to work,
I use a bike,
which costs 12 thousand
rupees per month.
Apart from this, if
we talk about the
bills, then gas 500,
water 500, electricity 4000.
That is 5000
rupees in total.
Most of the medicines
are free from the
government.
But still, I may
have to spend 500
rupees.
Apart from this, if
you add 500 rupees
for Wi-Fi and
700 rupees for soap,
shampoo, laundry, etc.
So it will be
a total of 38
,700 rupees, which
is more than my
salary.
So I have used
all my salary and
there is no entertainment
in it.
There is no fun,
there is no travel.
It does not have
emergency savings or money
for any difficult day.
It only has
the mental pressure of
getting the bike repaired
and the illness.
I may be one
of those Pakistanis who
borrow money
from their friends or
save money from them.
This means that my
full-time job, which
is more than the
minimum wage, is
not able to cover
my entire month.
I would have saved
some money if I
had my own house
and that house was
close to work.
And then I would
have spent that money
on my children's education.
Now let's see what
we can do with
a monthly salary of
75,000 rupees.
So let's assume that
my name is Fatima,
which represents a middle
-class income person.
I earn 75
,000 rupees a month
from a government college
in Fatima, Lahore.
After tax,
,750 rupees remain from
this 75,000 rupees.
So let's see what
happens with this.
My budget for a
house is 15,000
rupees.
In this 15,000
rupees, I have got
a big room
in a house where
a family already lives.
The college is very
far from my house,
but thanks to Lahore's
public transportation, I
will only have to
spend 3,000 rupees
a month.
So for food, I
have allocated 15,000
rupees, in which I
get good food.
Dal, roti, one or
two dinners can also
be eaten outside.
I have to be
careful about the prices,
but I have a
little room to eat
chicken.
The budget for health
can be saved from
the government hospital
if
it is close to
my house.
But maybe I will
have to spend 2
,500 rupees on medicines.
The bill will be
10,000 rupees.
Apart from this, Wi
-Fi, mobile load, beauty
products, soap, shampoo, detergents
will cost me 11
,000 rupees.
For shopping, I will
go for 12,000
rupees.
And even now, 10
,000 rupees can be
spent for children's private
school fees.
I still have 750
rupees left.
So if you add
everything together, then I
am doing much better
than Fatima Ahmed.
But not much.
Some emergency expenses
can still take Fatima
into debt.
Okay, so now let's
go for a salary
of 350,000 rupees.
Suppose my name is
Ahmed and I work
in SEWS.
This job gives me
350,000 rupees a
month.
I earn 9 times
more than Jameel and
4 times more than
Fatima in a month.
I am among the
top 5-10%
earners of Pakistan.
My salary gives me
350,000 rupees a
month, out of which
61,000 goes in
taxes.
After that, I have
2,88,750
rupees left.
I have a good
apartment for which I
pay 75,000 rupees
a month.
I can also buy
a good place to
live with my money.
My transport costs 30
,000 rupees.
I have my own
car and in this
30,000 rupees, the
fuel and maintenance of
that car, everything is
done.
I spend 40,000
rupees on food.
I eat in big
restaurants, buy good
groceries and don't focus
much on prices.
I spend 10
,000 rupees on health,
20,000 rupees on
bills and
,500 rupees on other
things.
30,000 rupees for
children's education in a
good private school.
20,000 rupees for
fun activities.
After that, I have
42,250
rupees left for savings,
investments and other
shortcomings.
I can take a
good and affordable place
in Pakistan and fill
my vacations every month.
This life is better
than many Pakistanis.
Now let's see how
a salary of 16
,00,000 rupees is
spent.
My name is Naveed.
I am studying a
very big post
in a big company
in Karachi.
I do big deals
and earn around 16
,00,000 rupees a
month.
After deducting the taxes,
I have around 11
,44,000 rupees left.
This means that in
a month, I earn
twice as much as
Jameel earns throughout the
year.
I am one of
the top 1%
Pakistanis.
My monthly expense is
2,00,000 rupees.
It is a luxury
villa in DHA.
It has a staff
to clean it and
many other things.
On transport, the expense
is 2,00,000
rupees.
There are cars, a
driver and flights.
I spend 1,50
,000 rupees on food.
I don't cook food.
In fact, I order
food from outside.
I go to big
restaurants and eat.
My chef cooks food
for me.
My health costs 50
,000 rupees.
There are private doctors.
There is no waiting.
After paying 50,000
rupees, I am one
of the 2%
families who
use more than 700
units of electricity.
I spend 2
,00,000 rupees on
my children's education.
My children go to
A-levels and O
-levels education where only
2% Pakistanis go.
My children go to
big universities in
Pakistan.
I spend 7,00
,000 rupees on entertainment,
savings and investment.
I enjoy my vacation
in the business class.
My life is unthinkable
for Jameel, Fatima and
Ahmed.
Now let's see what
happens when we take
our earnings to 500
crore rupees annually.
This is the earning
that some people really
do in Pakistan.
My name is Zahid.
I am the owner
of a big business
group.
My group includes banking,
real estate, textile and
everything.
If I am not
a politician, general or
a bureaucrat, then I
leave this country.
But I will try
to stay here for
my strength because my
real wealth is in
relationships.
Similarly, some of our
politicians are at the
same level.
So I have 41
crore rupees in a
month.
Naveed was one of
the top 1%
Pakistanis whereas I am
one of the elite
personalities in the world.
Let's talk about a
few things here.
The money that I
am telling you I
don't get it every
month or every year
in terms of income.
In fact, it is
my total net worth.
The money that I
have invested in stocks,
the houses that I
have bought, the properties
that I have, the
cars that I have,
the antique pieces that
I have, all of
them will be calculated
as my net worth.
So until I sell
my property, I will
not pay any tax
on it.
So I pay
less tax than Ahmed.
And this is my
benefit.
My real strength is
in relationships.
And I make these
relationships through marriages and
some deals through
which I am able
to break the laws
as per my will
and I am able
to avoid taxes.
So now let's see
how I will spend
this money.
I have a house
worth crores of rupees
which has a swimming
pool, gardens, and a
lot of luxurious things.
All these things keep
me away from the
hustle and bustle of
the outside world.
My area is full
of rich people.
It is very easy
for me to go
and come anywhere.
I don't have to
go through any kind
of poor people
to
go anywhere.
Not only in Pakistan,
but in other countries
as well, there are
luxurious houses and
hotels where I live
and do
business.
I am a crazy
rich guy.
That is why I
use so much money.
Maybe the people who
are actually present at
that place don't spend
money like this.
My children do not
study in Pakistan, but
in the best universities
in the world.
I spend 75
lakh rupees on my
transport which includes private
jets, cars, and
drivers.
I feel that 75
lakh rupees in Dubai
is equivalent to giving
50 rupees to Fatima.
I spend 50 lakh
rupees on food.
I have my own
private chefs, I eat
private food in Wanal,
and a lot of
other things.
I don't cook food,
but whenever I open
the fridge, everything in
the world is
present in it.
I go to the
shops and cook food
when I want to
feel like a normal
human
being.
I spend 50 lakh
rupees on my health.
I have my own
private doctors who are
always on my call.
Last year's 70 lakh
rupees implants are like
taking out 300
rupees for Ahmed.
I spend 10 lakh
rupees on my bills.
Apart from this, it
takes 7 crore
and 50 lakh rupees
for art and travel.
I give crores of
rupees to many big
universities for
funds.
This affects
my admissions.
Or I can give
lakhs of rupees to
my nephew's school in
Zakat and Sadaqat.
Even though he doesn't
need it, but
it affects my taxes
a lot.
It is surprising that
my one-hour income
is more than 6
months of Jameel's and
my one day is
more than 4 years
of his.
But I am not
worried about poverty, education,
or the health of
the poor.
Because I am fine.
As long as the
power of my neighbor
is not in danger.
A century ago, the
Nawabs of Pakistan collected
a lot of money.
And that tradition is
still intact.
All reforms failed.
Nobles like me broke
the country's system for
their own benefit.
Jameel's hut and my
palace.
And this conflict is
increasing.
In 1943, Qaid-e
-Azam said, Can you
imagine that lakhs of
people have been exploited?
People can't even eat
once a day.
If
this is what
Pakistan thinks, then I
will not accept it.
And unfortunately, even after
a century, we
could not make Pakistan
what Qaid-e-Azam
thought it was.
That's all for this
video.
Until the next video,
Allah Hafiz.
Pakistan Zindabad.